who's the better Jeff so I will say
internally we have been trying to break
up people into multiple different skill
groups I'm typically in the higher end
bracket he's typically sometimes the
higher bracket you know obviously he
plays a much better tank than I do I'll
say I think I haven't beaten sort of the
Widowmaker sort of hits confront though
[Music]
hey guys I'm Jeff Goodman and the lead
here designer of overwatch I'm
responsible for designing implementing
all the heroes and balancing as well
today I'm here to talk about sort of
batiste and how he showed up in the game
actually batiste started as a prototype
we originally called gadget actually
because the idea was we didn't really
know what here where he was gonna be we
didn't know what kind of character who's
gonna be it was just sort of this
accommodation of different gameplay
ideas and we wanted to see what kind of
work
so the first ability we actually started
with for him was what we call it at the
time the javelin or the lamp which is
what eventually became the immortality
field as everybody knows it as but
originally we called it lamp because I
didn't have any assets so I think I just
grabbed some random lamp assets like
sort of street lamp I don't remember
what map was from right now you know
originally it had this this actually
long sort of pole to because it was two
lamps and you know had this top much
like this has now and I had this kind of
like wide top like this kind of we still
want to make sure that you know if you
had the big Reinhardt shield in front of
it or something you could still block it
and that was a kind of a cool move you
could try to pull off but it was still
largely attackable so we have this sort
of space to work with here above the
characters but sort of below the
Rhinehart shield the big reason we went
away from an actual lamp object with
like a whole stem and everything was at
the time you threw it like a javelin or
spear which is why we sort of called her
that originally clever players of course
immediately started throwing it at weird
angles to try to keep the top down it
sticks out from the wall and you can't
shoot it anymore and stuff like that
it's funny we still actually call it
lamp internally if you can't get away
from it a lot of our internally I'm just
stick for so long
this is the first we called blockout
which is a really early model we're
deciding that we want to try to pursue
this as an actual full game mechanic and
we're willing to go pass like literally
like grabbing some random things so the
artists made this really quick block out
so we get an idea what it looks like
this is actually Mercy's little UI
element here in the middle here you can
see the screen effect was a lot louder
here sort of all these sides here I
think inevitably at this point what
tends to happen in development always is
we're constantly trying to get more
information because it's new new
character to us new information we
always end up kind of paring it back
this is like maybe a step two I would
say in the process of just past like the
very very first implementation so here
we have a video of what we call gadget
at the time which eventually became
Battiste so this is like a block at that
we then artists do real quick for me so
it's not meant to be super great quality
it's just supposed to like very much
differentiate the character so that's
why it's literally like I mean this is
like a square and another square another
square like it's really basic you can
see soldiers having six gun is still
here we didn't have a block a model for
that yet Ana's picture still in the
bottom left we haven't really gotten to
that all the bottom right UI stuff is
all from other characters the the
healing grenade here has started off I
don't remember I think I grabbed this
short tweak this from saria's alt fire
and tweet the colors and stuff it looks
really ugly I'm not usually going for
making it look really good I just want
it to be really clear hopefully when I'm
going to prototyping anyway so yeah this
was actually the original amplification
matrix it's obviously very very simple I
just went to Ryerson said hey could you
give me some really simple I don't want
to take any time but just like give me a
flat plain with a color on it like at
this point I still don't know if you
want to do this ability we're just
testing it but obviously this is a lot
bigger you know the normal tea sold as a
shipped with as much smaller it's
probably something closer to that so
this is maybe the the overpowered
version initially this is Jeff Kappa I'm
playing the original prototype and
always good at that off you gotta use
your abilities especially for showing
off the prototype better Jeff Kaplan
I've you know honestly he plays a much
better tank than I did I'll say like I'm
I'm actually pretty bad at tanks I tend
to be pretty aggressive and gets my team
killed a lot of times I think I haven't
beat on sort of the Widowmaker sort of
hits game front though so I will say we
have had a thing internally where we
would do a lot of play testing and we
have a lot of mixed skill levels I'm
typically in the
and Bracken he's typically sometimes the
higher bracket sometimes so early on
you'll notice one small thing here the
lamp effect did not actually cap you at
20% health that actually just stopped
you at one health so you could see it
here he stopped at one health here we
felt like we needed a little bit of
buffer after play testing it where maybe
you take a stray shot from like a tracer
or something that doesn't just kill you
instantly of course he gets Danny
boosted cuz wouldn't be a healer
prototype with that he were accidentally
getting that of a stick he started with
some more complicated abilities I can't
remember everything he had right now a
bunch of more deployable stuff so we
came up with this ability regenerative
burst
you hit the button in places he Hill
over time on everyone around you
including himself what is interesting
about this those originally actually
this little piece here in his chest
actually was meant to be for the
stability at the very beginning he was
going to jab to sing himself and then it
kind of healed everyone around him but
then it was conceptually got very
strange but how was he like
inject himself and then the flies around
him it doesn't really make a lot of
sense you know originally we were gonna
have this little spider thing here pull
it off for you directly but that piece
was there from an artistic standpoint we
wanted to add more sort of stuff on him
his backpack was really big and we
wanted to make it feel like he's got a
lot of equipment even stuff you're not
necessarily using a game he's just like
well equipped a pretty simple ability
but actually ended up being pretty core
to how you play him so his experts
ability are kind of interesting because
that definitely was not part of the
original prototype the original design
sort of intentionally had this crouched
forcing to Crouch ahead of time to
charge it that's kind of why it's a
passive it's more of a smaller effect on
him that does help to get up high places
in certain maps and follow your team if
they're jumping up high yeah it was it's
came really late and actually was ended
up being a great addition to him and
helped out a lot of situations yeah so
talking about a t7 it went through a
bunch there was a grenade launcher was
your primary and then he had a second
weapon to pull out which was more of a
submachine gun so then we ended up
merging the guns together to help
address the design concerns as well you
know obviously this big tank here feels
very grenade launcher very bulky and
that's very intentional because we want
to make sure that he still feels like a
healer and then he also has you know the
smaller barrel on top and you can see
that the kind of the bullets are in this
little chamber here we weren't sure how
the reloads gonna work we talked about
doing maybe like three different
animations is it like I hit the button
if I'm just missing bullets and then it
does someone animation and then hit the
button if I'm just missing grenades to
do a different animation and there may
be a third one like if I'm missing both
it's like a longer animation
and they convert gameplay standpoint
this is a much better result so now you
can freely use both ammo types in fact
you're someone incentivized to use both
ammo types because the longer you can go
without reloading the better so I think
we ended up in a good spot there
so yeah this whole this whole page we're
sort of we developed pretty late and
that includes difficulty as well we're
you know we could be changing and we
took a mortality field away from him
that takes away a lot of a difficulty in
playing him as an example the difficulty
conversation actually is pretty quick
it's not usually that can even a meeting
per se it kind of just you know a lot of
the designers at this point are sitting
right next to each other and we're kind
of like hey we got a difficulty what do
you guys think and at this point we've
been playing him for months so we have a
pretty good idea of how he plays and how
difficulty is relative to other heroes
and other healers the difficulty stars
are a pretty simple thing at that point
usually because we're so late in the
process yeah so right near the end of
the process where we're pretty heads
down on fixing bugs and sort of issues
were finding fine-tuning some balance
issues you know as we add more and more
heroes to the game those are more common
we would never release a hero we weren't
happy with or we didn't think was ready
to go but it's definitely like down to
the wire a lot of times you can we have
a lot of bug triage meetings where we
all sit down and looking at all the bugs
and make sure we fix the really
important massive ones and so far I
don't remember ever having to fully
actually delay a patch and delay a hero
but honestly we came pretty close to the
Battiste we're talking about if we
didn't get those amplification mixers to
look in a way that we're really happy
with and be really obvious then we might
have had to delay a little bit but I
think we got there and we're really
happy with the result I am going to
fight for a better world for some that
means a bandage for others
a lot of what you're doing as a designer
is sort of a lot of intuition and how
things feel and how things are working
the way you want them to I draw from
light inspiration from everywhere so and
play a lot of different genres so it
helps to have that I think these days
were released so many heroes it's almost
all excitement there's a little bit of
fear I'm always a little worried that
you know people will find it as fun or
interesting as I do but I think it's
mostly just super excited to get it out
there and go to people's hands and
getting people's feedback of reactions
right away and that's like the best day
is like when it shows up on PTR and
people are like I have like three or
four twitch channels open and I have all
the reddit and our forms open it's like
my whole day is just like watching
reactions and getting a feedback from
people it's great
[Music]